[Música]
bienvenidos al enlace conosur desde
chile hoy el tema del programa será el
agua a propósito de la celebración de su
día mundial si él es el único país del
mundo donde el agua es un bien de uso
privado algo que quedó consagrado en la
constitución del dictador augusto
pinochet que data de 1980 es el código
de aguas de 1981 el que rige los
derechos de propiedad del agua que
fueron distribuidos de forma gratuita a
personas poderosas y privilegiadas hoy
en muchos lugares del país este uso de
un bien público se cede en negocios
multimillonarios la desigualdad que
azota chile se reproduciría también en
el sistema de distribución del agua
según un estudio de 2020 de los 29 mil
personas que existen en el país que
tienen títulos de propiedad consultivos
del agua un 1% acumularía el 79 por
ciento del agua que existe en el sistema
la sequía y en algunos casos la mala
gestión hídrica ha llevado a que lugares
como éste un antiguo el lago y lugar
turístico desaparezcan casi
completamente
no nos encontramos en la parte que es la
parte más profunda del embalse peñuelas
y podemos ver acá
lo poco que está quedando de agua en el
embalse
se aprecia también el terreno cómo está
todo resquebrajado producto de la baja
que ha tenido paulatinamente el este
embalse no de las 1.700 hectáreas que
debiese tener en un año o en una
estación normal de embalsamiento lo que
tenemos hoy día acá es supera con suerte
la hectárea de agua o sea estamos
hablando de
un porcentaje bajísimo de la capacidad
normal no llega al 1% este el registro
más bajo que tenemos a la fecha ha sido
un polo digamos de esparcimiento para la
familia un atractivo turístico pero por
la baja que tiene el lago la visitación
también ha ido disminuyendo daño
normales con mucha agua podríamos tener
miles de gaviotas asociada al espejo de
agua entre otras muchas especies
lamentablemente lo que vemos son aves
carroñeras que se están comiendo los
últimos peces que están quedando en el
embalse que se están muriendo ya sea por
la falta de oxígeno o por la temperatura
que tiene el agua para mí personalmente
es como mi segundo hogar prácticamente
mi padre fue guardaparques de esta
reserva nacional yo cuando nací mis
papás vivían acá pena es una pena para
mí verlo cómo está hoy día tan bajo
y tiene un significado muy importante en
mi vida profesional y en mi vida
personal también mis hijos también me
dicen usted ya no trabaja en el lago
peñuelas esto no es un lago no tiene
agua lo que se está evidenciando acá es
eso un aumento de la temperatura
promedio o baja pluviometría nos lleva a
concluir de que esto tiene que ver con
efectos del cambio climático por la baja
tan rápido que tiene es que
probablemente llegue a eso o peor
la nueva constitución que elaboran 154
convencionales constituyentes en chile
tiene una mirada claramente enfocada al
medio ambiente donde el aspecto de la
restitución del agua como un bien
público será fundamental hablamos de
esto con carolina vilches elegida
convencional constituyente por su
trabajo en organizaciones sociales como
el movimiento para el acceso al agua a
la tierra y la protección del medio
ambiente modatima organización premiada
en varios países entre ellos es francia
por su labor carolina como de qué va a
quedar reflejado el tema del agua en la
nueva constitución y cuánto se ha
avanzado y al respecto bueno estamos en
este proceso histórico constituyente que
claramente viene a superar el
sufrimiento que han tenido las personas
familias y comunidades
entonces se sobreexplota el agua en
donde se plantan los cerros y donde hoy
día se necesita agua para el consumo
humano de manera urgente sobre todo
enfrentando una pandemia como la que
estamos viendo en todo el mundo para
nosotros superar la naturaleza jurídica
del agua como bien nacional de uso
público y pasar a hacer un bien común
natural in apropiable es parte central
de nuestra propuesta que va al pleno de
la convención lo que hacemos es
priorizar
sumo humano por sobre el uso industrial
pero también terminar con la apropiación
de las aguas y además constituir una
nueva institucionalidad en materia
hídrica que resuelva la descoordinación
y la de la dispersión institucional que
hoy día existe que significa que la
institucionalidad nueva en materia
hídrica de garantías de control de
fiscalización y de una reasignación
equitativa que entregue justicia a los
territorios que han sido privados del
agua la convención constitucional tiene
como vemos la difícil labor de aquí a
julio de este año de dibujar un nuevo
chile que incluya una mejor
redistribución de sus recursos naturales
también del agua estaremos pendientes de
sus avances hasta aquí esta edición de
enlace conocer chile los esperamos en un
próximo programa